in the price-to-earnings conundrum video
we encountered a situation where two
different entrepreneurs bought an
identical asset in this case it was a
pizza parlor or pizzeria but they each
financed it in a different way this guy
was a little bit more conservative he
paid for it outright so the entire asset
was his equity he had no debt well this
guy he borrowed some money and he even
had some non operating assets so he
levered up for every dollar he put in he
borrowed ten dollars from the bank in
order to buy more asset that he actually
brought to the table and we saw that
when you did their financial statements
their revenue cost of goods everything
up to the operating profit line was the
same and that makes sense because if we
if you remember the first introduction
to income statement video operating
profit is really indicative of what the
operating assets are generating so in
this case it's what DS purple the purple
area right here are generating you could
also consider that the enterprise
do what the enterprise is generating and
everything below the operating line
everything below the operating profit
line is either coming from non operating
assets that would be the case of non
operating income and the entrepreneur on
the right had some of that he had some
of this non operating income
$2,000 per year in that case while this
guy didn't have any and then you have
expenses associated with interest right
in this case this entrepreneur had 5% of
$100,000 of $5,000 a year and then when
you have these differences in capital
structure it changes what your net
income is and they had slightly
different net income numbers but what we
saw is when we applied the same price to
earnings ratio and had the same the
share counts I didn't change too many
variables here I just really changed how
they paid for the asset but when you
have when you applied the same price to
earnings ratio - both - both earnings
streams - both companies you got
something that was reasonably
unintuitive and and I you know there's
no trick here really because it's not
crazy to assign the same price to
earnings ratio and if you try it out if
you grow this guy's revenue a little bit
if you actually grow both
their revenues by the same amount or
both of their gross profits by the same
amount or if you grow both of their
operating profits by the same amount
you're actually going to see that this
guy's earnings per share is growing
faster so given that someone might say
oh because of a leverage maybe I'm
willing to pay even a higher multiple so
it's not crazy to pay the same multiple
for both of these guys but we saw at the
end of the last videos when you apply
let's say a ten multiple or really any
any multiple to both of these earning
streams you get you get a situation that
first doesn't look crazy okay the market
cap of this guy is 210,000 if you apply
ten multiple to their earnings stream
while the market cap of this guy is one
hundred eighty nine thousand if you
apply a ten multiple to their earning
stream right ten times eighteen point
nine thousand is one hundred eighty nine
thousand ten times twenty one thousand
is two hundred ten thousand but what was
the conundrum what really got us
thinking was how can this hole this
equity stream right here or this equity
or this earning stream be worth two
hundred ten and this one be worth one
hundred eighty nine when this guy only
put ten thousand initially and this guy
put in a hundred thousand he put it ten
times as much and if you wanted to value
so when you were paying two hundred ten
thousand for this asset for this equity
you're essentially saying that this
asset is worth two hundred ten thousand
but if you're saying that this equity is
worth one hundred eighty nine thousand
right that's what the market cap is it's
the value of the equity then you're
implicitly saying that this asset that
all of these assets are worth the value
of this market capitalization plus this
debt right so that's two hundred eighty
nine thousand and then if you wanted the
value of this operating asset you would
subtract out this much right here the
cash so you got something like two
hundred seventy nine thousand so when
you apply the same price to earnings to
the same just these similar businesses
you actually got a situation where
you're overpaying for this for this
asset relative to this one even though
they're identical so they had left off
so the question is what do we do why did
the why what what can we use other than
a price to earnings ratio and that's
what this video is for so the short
answer is one you do have to use
something different price to earnings
ratio is a good quick way of comparing
two companies relative to their growth
or relative to an industry but it does
lose a lot of information relative to
how
the companies are capitalized and you
saw in the last video that how you're
capitalized when I say capitalized I
mean how do you pay for your assets if
you have a lot of debt versus a lot of
equity what actually happens on the
earnings line is very very different and
so you lose all of that information and
so if you want to capture that
information when you look at the price
of a stock you have to figure out what
you're actually paying for the
enterprise of the company the enterprise
value of the company so when I talk
about the enterprise or the enterprise
value I'm talking about the operating
assets if it's a you know it gets a
little bit more complicated if you're
talking about a financial company like a
bank or an insurance company but if
we're talking about a widget Factory the
enterprise is essentially the assets the
asset value enterprise value is the
asset value of the assets that allow the
company to do business so whatever
factories well in this case it's a
pizzeria so the ovens the building the
the the actual places with this the
places where people actually eat their
food and even the cash that's necessary
to operate the business it's not the
enterprise value shouldn't incorporate
the cash that's surplus that's not
necessary to operate the business so
that that begs the question how do you
calculate the enterprise value so you
could go backwards and you say okay for
a given price how much am I paying for
an enterprise value so let's say that
this stock let's say that Company A or
this one let's say that stock right now
is trading at let's say it's trading at
20 let's say it's trading at 20 dollars
while companies B so this is the current
price then you could buy it at so it's
the asking price in the market is it $20
while this one is at let's say it's at
10 dollars its at 10 dollars so at first
glance you might just do a quick price
to earnings ratio and you'll say okay
for 20 dollars I'm getting I'm getting
what 2 dollars and 10 learnings per year
assuming it's not growing or something
so my price to earnings is approximately
I don't know I don't have my calculator
in front of me but 220 divided by two
dollars 10 it's gonna be nine point
something something right well this guy
for ten dollars I am paying I'm getting
a
89 of earnings per year so what's a
hundred divided by 18 it's like it's
five or six times it's going to be five
points something five six times 18 is 60
plus yeah it's gonna be five point
something something so when you
superficially just look at this you can
say well this is a cheaper price to
earnings ratio maybe I should buy that
but would you II saw in the last video
is that price to earnings isn't a good
relative valuation metric when two
different companies are capitalized very
differently so what you want to do is
instead back out what these prices imply
about the enterprise value so what does
$20 imply about the enterprise value and
what is $10 imply and how do you do that
well first you say what is the market
cap market cap so you take the price
times the number of shares if you
remember we had 10,000 shares so in this
case 20 times 10,000 shares implies a
$200,000 market cap in this case we have
$10 times 10,000 shares so it implies a
hundred thousand dollar market cap now
remember the market cap is just what's
left over so if let me redraw those
those two diagrams because I feel like
I'm so in for this entrepreneur you have
the assets and all of the X and and
there's no debt so the assets are kind
of completely represented by the equity
so if the market cap is $200,000 you're
essentially saying that these assets
these operating assets are worth
$200,000 so in this case when the
weather at a price of at a price of $20
we know that the enterprise value the
market enterprise value so what the
market is saying the enterprise is worth
the operating assets are worth is
$200,000 now in this case remember the
market is saying that the equity is
worth $100,000 let me draw that the
market is saying that the equity is
worth $100,000 but of course this
company has a lot of debt it has another
hundred thousand dollars of debt
actually let me let me draw this a
little bit different let me see how much
I can erase and I can't erase it like
that
let me erase this thing alright so in
this situation the market is saying that
its market cap is $100,000 so just to be
proportional let me draw it like that
nope didn't want to use that one
this is $100,000 this is the equity or
the market capitalization or the market
value of the equity that's what the
market cap is and that's just the price
times the number of shares and then it
has debt it has if I remember correctly
it has $100,000 and it has $100,000 in
debt if you take $100,000 $100,000
$100,000 in debt $100,000 and so what is
it saying about the assets so the equity
plus the debt or the liabilities is
$200,000 so saying all of the assets are
worth $200,000 $200,000 all right this
is all of the assets $200,000 but what
we need to do we want to figure out the
value of the enterprise not just all of
the assets so if we remember there was
some of the assets that were actually
operational and some were non
operational so we had $10,000 of cash
right there so we have $10,000 of cash
$10,000 of cash so when this stock is
trading at ten dollars it implies a
market capitalization of $100,000 it
implies that the liabilities plus equity
is $200,000 so all of the assets are
200,000 but if we were to subtract out
the cash or the non operating assets
what's not necessary to operate the
business we get $190,000 of enterprise
value so in this case they're saying
that the enterprise value is $190,000 so
in this case when you looked at the
price to earnings like wow this is half
as expensive as that this is a great
deal let me buy it
and I just happened to make up the
numbers so that even when I did the
enterprise value still but it's only 5%
cheaper here it looks 50% cheaper here
it looks 5% cheaper and so it might be a
little unintuitive of you know to figure
out the enterprise value you take and
this will see this will be the formula
you see in a lot of books and a prized
value is equal to market cap market cap
plus debt minus cash and you might be
like when I'm trying to value something
why should I add debt back that debt is
a negative thing isn't shouldn't debt
make my enterprise worth less and why am
i subtracting cash because cash is a
positive thing shouldn't that make my
enterprise value more and the reason why
well first you subtract cash is and it
really should be just cash that is not
associated with the enterprise and
you'll see a lot of people do it in
different ways some people will subtract
out all cash with the argument that the
company doesn't need to use any of it
but what but the real idea behind it is
to kind of capture the assets that are
actually generating the profits of the
enterprise and the enter the profits of
the enterprise are the operating profits
and the reason why you add debt is think
about it this way if you wanted to buy
out this company if you wanted to buy
let's say from this company you wanted
to buy his assets at the market price
how would you do it well you would have
to pay what you would you would have to
maybe get $200,000 right if you got
200,000 dollars you could buy these guys
off you could pay them $100,000 and own
that and then you could buy the bank out
pay them a hundred thousand dollars so
you paid two hundred thousand dollars
you would own all of this right this
would all be your equity and then you
would get a $10,000 back if you know if
you wanted to to take this cash right so
you would have essentially paid two
hundred thousand dollars which is the
market cap plus the debt that's what you
would have had to do to buy out both of
those I guess you could say stakeholders
in the company and then you would get
back the cash so you would have to pay
net $190,000 to own this enterprise and
hopefully that makes a little bit more
sense as why the enterprise value is
actually described this way now the one
thing you might say okay Sal you figure
how to calculate enterprise value from a
share price but what if I want to go the
other way around how do I figure out
what a company's enterprise value should
be and then figure out its what its
share price should be well one metric
and there's two metrics
the most common metric that's used is
EBIT de yi bit da I won't cover that now
cuz I it's a new term for you but it
means earnings before interest taxes
depreciation and amortization and people
look at something called an enterprise
value to EBIT da ratio and I'll do that
in the next video but what I like to do
is just think about okay what are the
real earnings from the enterprise well
that's the operating profit that's the
operating profit right and then you can
apply a multiple to that based on what
other companies are trading at or how
fast it's growing so let's say in this
case we're saying they're both
generating thirty thousand dollars in
operating profit per year let's say that
I want to apply a a I don't know I want
to apply a five multiple to its
operating profits so let's say I want to
say that that evey to operating profit
which I frankly think is a better metric
than evey to EBIT da and I'll cover you
but on a future video let's say that I
think for this industry it should be
five
let me say it should be six six times is
a good multiple so in both those cases
the operating profit operating profit
was thirty thousand dollars so that
means that evey should be thirty
thousand dollars times six which is
equal to one hundred and eighty thousand
dollars now for the first guy if the if
the Evie is one hundred eighty thousand
dollars so I'm saying that this thing
right here the market value should be
one hundred eighty thousand dollars that
I'm implying that the equity should be
worth $180,000 and they are there's
there are ten thousand shares right so
what I essentially I would take that
Evie and I would say well that's though
all of that's equity there's no cash
there there's no debt so all of this is
equity so I would divide that by the
shares so I would say that the market
cap for the first guy should be one
hundred eighty thousand and so the per
share price
the price I'd be willing to pay is $18
because it had 10,000 shares right $18
now let's take the second guy situation
we both agree in both situations their
enterprise value should be 180,000 this
right here should be $180,000
but in this guy's case what is the what
are the assets the assets are the
enterprise 180 plus 10 plus 10k right
this whole left hand side is $190,000
and then the market and then if you
wanted to subtract out a figure out the
market cap you would take this whole
thing and then subtract out the debt to
get the market cap right and then you
would be left with this piece right here
that right there right you were just
figuring out this whole distance
subtracting out this distance so
essentially you say that the market cap
is equal to the enterprise value plus
the cash minus the debt and it's good to
draw those balance sheets if you ever
get confused minus the debt so the
market cap is equal to one ninety minus
one hundred K is equal to ninety K and
so if you divide that by 10,000 shares
you'd say that I'm willing to pay nine
dollars per share so if you believe that
the enterprise value of these pizzerias
are identical and that they're both
worth $180,000 you should be willing to
pay $18 for Company A and if you're
completely equivalent to it you should
pay nine dollars for Company B and now
if you're a little bit more aggressive
you might like the leverage you like
might like how Company B is growing etc
maybe you like to play a premium for
that leverage or maybe you wouldn't
because it also increases your risk
because you get leverage on the upside
or on the downside but anyway I wanted
to introduce you to enterprise value in
the next video I'll introduce you to E
bit de